I have a very contrasting set of comments
from the other candidate to play for you.
Joe Biden came out last night before Donald
Trump around 1:00 a.m., roughly in the morning
East Coast time.
And he was notable in that he behaved like
a normal person.
We didn't know at the time and we still don't
know now who is the winner of the race.
And Joe Biden doesn't come out like Trump
and say, I won.
Joe Biden doesn't come out and say I won states
that haven't actually been called, which Donald
Trump did.
Joe Biden comes out and makes it clear we
knew it would take a while and we believe
we still have a path to winning, which is
true.
He may not win, but as I showed you earlier,
earlier, in exquisite detail, he does have
a path.
Here's Joe Biden.
Your patience is commendable.
We knew this was going to go wrong, but who
knew?
We're going to go into maybe tomorrow morning,
maybe even longer.
But, look, we feel good about where we are.
We really do.
I'm here to tell you tonight we believe we're
on track to win this election, so, of course,
Joe Biden is optimistic, as any campaign would
be until it's clear you're not going to win.
But unlike Donald Trump, Joe Biden is being
a responsible adult.
Joe Biden is not declaring a victory that
he doesn't have.
Joe Biden is not declaring victories in states
that have not been called and which, in fact,
as Donald Trump said, we're winning Wisconsin
and Michigan.
Those states flipped to Joseph R. Biden Jr.
Notice that Joe Biden doesn't claim a victory
absent an actual victory to claim he doesn't
alleged fraud, abuse and actual fraud, to
claim he doesn't say he will go to court to
try to stop ballots from being counted.
The contrast is stunning.
And the fact that so many Americans don't
care is a problem, which I am going to get
to a little bit later.
Increasingly, Joe Biden's path depends on
Pennsylvania, although as I said earlier,
even without it, Biden can win with Nevada,
Michigan and Wisconsin.
But Joe Biden says they feel good about Pennsylvania.
This was last night.
We still have to see how the numbers come
in.
But we're feeling good.
We're feeling good about where we are.
We believe one of the nets has suggested we've
already won Arizona, but we're confident about
Arizona.
That's a turnaround.
We're also just called in for Minnesota and
we're still in the game in Georgia, although
that's not what we expected.
We're feeling good about Wisconsin and Michigan.
And by the way, it's going to take time to
count the votes, we're going to win Pennsylvania.
And as we will continue to see Pennsylvania,
if it were to flip back to Biden as that remaining
35 percent of the vote is counted, it could
be a huge part of Biden's path to victory.
If indeed he gets it, it would be the ultimate
red mirage scenario, a major, major factor.
And then lastly, here is Joe Biden saying
we could know the results as early as tomorrow
morning, but it is not up to him to say when
it is final.
It is up to the American people and of course,
the people actually counting the ballots.
Take a look at this.
Look, you know, we could know the results
as early as tomorrow morning, but it may take
a little longer.
As I've said all along, it's not my place
or Donald Trump's place to declare who's won
this election.
That's the decision of the American people.
But I'm optimistic about this outcome.
I thank every one of you who came out and
vote in this election.
And by the way, Chris Coons and the Democrats,
congratulations here in Delaware.
So the contrasts continue.
If you thought with the wackiness would stop
on Election Day, you were very wrong.
Joe Biden acting like a normal person connected
to reality, not a delusional narcissist.
It's nice for a change.
Donald Trump coming out in a rally like atmosphere,
claiming he won, claiming he won states in
which leads were evaporating literally as
he spoke, claiming fraud and claiming he will
go to the Supreme Court.
It's incredible, guys.
It's incredible.
We need to maintain our democratic systems.
And Donald Trump is taking a sledgehammer
or a chef's knife or whatever, a sword, anything
Donald Trump could pick up with those hands
of his.
And we need to protect democracy will continue
covering this on Instagram, where you can
find us at The David Pakman Show.
Follow me on Instagram at David Pakman, The
David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.